every time i try to talk about the
loudly hypothesis with my peers i'm shut
down and berated people seem to have
total apathy towards the origin of covid
why is this any advice this is totally
related to the last question different
person
um but uh but you know i don't i
i think we've all been informed people
who get their news from left-leaning
publications have been informed that
apathy is the only at some level the
only patriotic response
that to to to be thinking about it
is frankly now to be a cyanophobe uh to
you know you're racist you're
secretly gonna you know hoping that
trump is in office like i don't even
know what
exactly it is but there's just a whole
lot of societal level control behind
this thing that comes out looking like
apathy yes you've been
predisposed to believe that if you
question this thing that bad stuff will
happen to you so people are
rationalizing not doing it
there's also though a problem where
because people don't understand
evolution or complex systems i hear all
the time well
probably it makes no difference where it
came from in terms of what we will do
about it
um but it would be good to know or why
do we need to know
we wouldn't change anything about how we
approach it which is absolutely and then
your motives are suspect why do you care
so much
right yeah but this is absolutely not
true right to the extent that we are
talking about something
that may have been modified in a lab it
has every implication or at least
potentially has every implication
for what we would do and what we would
predict and therefore how we might
modify our behavior and basically when
somebody tells you well
it doesn't make any difference they're
telling you they don't understand how
evolution works because
we're really asking you know where did
it come from
well if it came from a lab that was
trying to make it more transmissible
between humans
in order to study its effect
then that's a whole set of information
about what the thing is
and how it behaves of course it's going
to have implications so
um you know i think the answer is sorry
you just
failed the logic part of the test yeah
um
you know try again yeah
you